SAMRAT RAY: Hi,
today we are going
to talk about how you can evolve
to a zero trust security model
with Anthos.
I am Samrat Ray.
I am the product management
lead for Anthos security
at Google Cloud.
And with me is Sandra.
SANDRA GUO: My
name is Sandra Guo.
I'm a security product
manager for Google Cloud.
SAMRAT RAY: And today
we'll talk about how
you can implement zero
trust security with Anthos.
But before we talk
about how you can do it,
let's first talk about
what is zero trust.
Then we talk to folks
outside of Google,
we hear many
different definitions
of what is zero trust.
We hear terms like, it's micro
or even nano segmentation
done at the workload level.
We have heard terms
like, perimeterless.
We have heard somebody say
it's something as narrow
as, hey, I have
implemented mTLS,
therefore I am doing zero trust.
We have heard definitions
from vendors and others
saying things like
trust endpoint
and not the network, continuous
track monitoring, all of this
is zero trust.
So in order to make
sense of this term,
we decided that we will give
it a clear definition rooted
in certain sets of principles
as we understand it at Google,
and then explain how
we're implementing
parts of those
principles using Anthos.
So how do we think about
the term zero trust?
The first way of
thinking about it
is to think about the
term trust, right.
And instead of focusing
on the word zero,
because we all understand--
there's a bit of a marketing
spin there--
we think about the
reducing privilege or trust
on all production
entities, right,
with respect to data, critical
workloads, and infrastructure.
So what we are saying is, we
don't trust any one thing.
It's not just about
network security.
It is bigger than that.
Rather than that,
we think about it
as a series of controls
for defense in depth.
And those controls include
infrastructure security,
border deployment security,
production network access,
and employee or insider access.
We have described
our approach that
covers all of these dimensions
through a paper called
BeyondProd.
And this is available
for you to read.
We highly recommend that
you take a look that.
Now let's talk about how we
can take these principles
and implement them with Anthos.
Before we dive into
the how, let's talk
about another aspect, why.
Why is this approach
suddenly relevant to you?
The reason for this being
important and gaining
more and more relevance
with our customers
is the confluence of
three technology trends.
The first is a hybrid
and multi-cloud.
We're seeing increasingly that
the production environment
is changing from a single
homogeneous production
environment, right, without
perhaps a single network,
to a distributed production
environment, spanning
multiple clouds,
and on-premises,
with different
network architectures,
and not having a consistent way
of viewing network security.
This means that the traditional
parameter-based security
approaches no longer apply
as well as they did before.
Second is the adoption of
containers and of Kubernetes.
The adoption of
containers, in particular,
implies that your
traditional security that
was based upon securing
the host and trusting
the host, i.e., at the
infrastructure level,
is no longer sufficient
because the strong correlation
between a workload
and its host is
no longer true with Kubernetes.
Therefore, in addition to
securing your infrastructure,
you now need to
rethink about how
you're securing your
workloads that are deployed
to this infrastructure.
There many of
those workloads may
be deployed on the same node.
And a single workload may be
deployed on multiple nodes
throughout this level.
The last dimension
is that option
of service-based architectures.
So we are seeing the breaking
of monoliths into microservices.
This is great from a developer
velocity perspective.
The challenge being, we
have now suddenly increase
the surface area of access
within your production
network by several
magnitudes, thus you now
need to ensure that you are
properly securing access
to sensitive infrastructure
and to sensitive data
within your production
network, and not just relying
on [INAUDIBLE] controls
that you had before.
So all of these
trends together mean
that we need to revisit
how we are doing security.
And zero trust is a
great way of thinking
about how security can
appropriately apply
in this modern environment.
So how can Anthos help?
Before we talk about
what Anthos does for you,
just want to set the context
that in this presentation,
we are only going to talk
about zero trust approaches
to production workload security.
We're not going to talk
about infrastructure
security or parameter security.
You can apply zero trust
approaches to those dimensions
as well, we're just not
covering them today.
We're going to focus
on workload security.
So with Anthos, we enable
you to think about zero trust
along three macro principles.
The first being, only trusted
code and configuration
can be applied to production.
The second is that
trust is not associated
with just the network
location of the workload,
but is actually associated
with who the workload is
and the user, on behalf of
which the workload is accessing
any other system
on the production.
The third is to make sure
that all service access is
granted to the right peer
and under the right request
context.
So now we'll talk about
how you can actually
implement these principles in
your production environment
with Anthos technologies.
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Sandra
to walk you through the
Anthos workload lifecycle.
SANDRA GUO: Thank you, Samrat.
If we take a look at
workload lifecycle,
it can roughly be
categorized into two phases,
so deploy phase, and the runtime
phase, with production identity
acting as a linchpin that
ties together the two phases.
So provenances can be tied--
so what is the right
production identity?
It can tie together as a
provenance to the production
privileges that a
workload can assume,
and ultimately the
production resources
that the workload can access.
So the goal for
the deploy phase is
to ensure that only
trusted workload can assume
the right production identity.
Then during the runtime
phase, making sure
that secure accesses are carried
out only by trusted production
identities.
If we take a closer look
at the deploy phase,
we realize that production
identities are typically
associated with a scope
to runtime environments,
such as the namespace
or a cluster.
Then the deploy
production security goal
can roughly be translated to
ensure only trusted workload
can be deployed
to the designated
trusted environments.
So what exactly is
a trusted workload?
So there are a common
set of risks associated
with deploying a workload.
The workload deployed may be
built from untrusted code,
in an untrusted environment, and
the typical mitigation for that
is to make sure it's
built centrally,
and also make sure
that is signed
by the centralized
process that views it,
so that it can be
verified later on.
The workload may include
a vulnerable package.
To help with that,
all images should
be scanned for no
vulnerabilities
before they are deployed.
But again, that
is not sufficient
because you have to act on
the vulnerability findings
by, again, signing
it, that verifies
that the vulnerability
scan bar has been reached
before a workload is deployed.
And then what about workloads
that are not sufficiently
tested or reviewed?
Again, it is not sufficient
that the necessary tests
are performed.
There should also be
evidences, such a signature
that a workload passes
all necessary tests.
Once a workload is
approved for deployment,
it may still be deployed
with a wrong configuration,
such as wrong as root.
That is why it's important to
have configuration guardrails
to catch those mistakes.
Last but not least,
the workload that
is approved for one
environment may not
be suitable for
the other, so it's
important to have
deploy policies that
are environmentally
appropriate, to only admit
workloads that are approved
for the target environment.
In summary, if we put in
place all of these controls,
we should have
trusted workload that
are viewed from the right code,
through the right process,
and deployed with the
right configuration
to the right environment.
Anthos offers tools and
products to implement zero trust
deployments and
all of the controls
that we described in
the previous slide.
Customer can choose to use
Cloud Build, or other CI
tools to implement a centralized
lock down CSV process.
And they can build
workload using
secure managed-base images
that are continuously
scanned and patched
for vulnerabilities.
Once the image is viewed, and
it gets checked into the Google
Container Registry,
it gets picked up
by the vulnerability scanner.
Google also hosts a
contender analysis API
that serves as a
container knowledge base,
that stores metadatas, findings,
build records, test results,
so that all the information
associated with a container
can be found in one place
for verification later on.
Once the image is
ready to be deployed,
a key part of the security
control is deploy policy.
Binary authorization
ensures that only explicitly
authorized image can be
deployed to the target runtime
environment.
For example, customer can set
a policy for their PCI clusters
to only allow images
from a centralized
build pipeline that also meets
their vulnerability scanning
bars.
Let's take a closer look
at binary authorization.
Binary authorization defines
an attestation framework
using signature verification.
So CSV components
can sign or attest
an image, as it passes
through each of the required
stages in the release process.
The user can then require
certain attestations
to be present at deploy
time, to make sure
that the required stages
in the release process
were actually carried out.
This mechanism
allows the customer
to control what can be deployed,
in addition to who can deploy.
One may have different policies
for each of the production
environments.
For example,
customers may require
images deployed to
the PCI environment
to be signed off by the
compliance stakeholders,
in addition to meeting the
regular test and quality
bars for regular
production environments.
In addition to
signature verification,
binary authorization
also supports
an allow list for certain third
party images that are deployed
in the user's environment.
The security team, for
example, can make it explicit,
which third party
images and versions
is allowed across
their organization,
so it makes it very easy
to manage and operate.
And then there are also
break glass processes,
in case there is a
production emergency
and the workload needs to
be pushed without satisfying
the necessary release
requirement, in which case
the deployment will
be logged in autolog
and can be reviewed later on.
In the end, with the
binary authorization,
every workload that gets
released into the production
environment can
be accounted for.
It should be either
built by the customer
and signed by their centralized
builder and processors,
or is explicitly whitelisted
from vendor images,
or if is a Google
provided system
image, that is whitelisted by
default using a system policy.
In addition to
binary authorization,
here are additional
product features
of Anthos for secure deployment.
The Google Container Registry
offers a vulnerability
scanning feature that
provides detailed insights
for known vulnerabilities
for checking images.
Once the initial scan's
done, it continues
to perform incremental
scannings every time
the vulnerability is updated.
User gets vulnerability
updates, even
for images that are
already running.
And those config
management makes
it easy to set up
configuration guardrails.
So it offers both customizable
and building policies,
such as requiring strict
mTLS for all services
in a particular namespace.
And then managed base images are
a set of container-based images
host, I'll call it
marketplace, that
are maintained and
regularly patched by Google.
They're used for
Google's own products
and are a good place to start
when building application
containers.
Now that we have looked
over the product features,
let's do a quick recap.
So we take a look at the
workload life cycle again.
Code from approved sources
are used in a locked down,
centralized build process to
produce a workload container.
And the workload container
then get tested and scanned
for known vulnerabilities.
Then as part of
the release process
for that workload during
the deployment stage,
it gets verified by
final authorization
against deploy
policies, to ensure
that it meets the
customer requirements
and has come from
a trusted process.
At this point,
trust your workload
has assumed the right
production identity
by running on the designated
production environment.
I'm now going to
hand over to Samrat
to describe how to secure this
workload while it's running.
SAMRAT RAY: Thank you, Sandra.
We now have a trusted workload
that we can trust, in addition
to just trusting the network.
All right, this allows us
now to have a different basis
of trust, which is rooted in
the workload and its identity,
rather than on just the network.
We will now talk about how
we can leverage this workload
identity to securely grant
access to sensitive data
and to sensitive infrastructure
in our production environment.
So how do we trust
a production client?
The way to trust a
production client
is to mitigate a number
of risks associated
with access within a
production environment.
These risks include access to
payload by entities listening
on the production network.
It includes things like
untrusted workload,
replaying application
credentials
to gain access to data.
All right, so some stolen
navigation credentials
can be used to then
gain access to data,
which the workload is
not supposed to gain,
have access to.
And so another
risk that is there
is a client impersonating
a more privileged workload.
And similarly, a
compromised client
can not only impersonate
a privileged workload,
but a compromised
client can also
exfiltrate all user
data that it has access
to on its own privilege.
Lastly, an insider
can also gain access
to sensitive data and
sensitive backends
without going through
appropriate checks
by bypassing certain frontends.
So all of these risks
exist in terms of access
within a production network.
So the corresponding
set of controls
that we can use to
mitigate these risks
are, we can ensure that
all workload to workload
communication is encrypted in
transit to prevent entities
that are listening
on the network
from gaining access
to sensitive data,
and credentials, et cetera.
We can ensure that all
clients are explicitly
authorized, such that untrusted
clients don't gain access,
even if they have the right
application level credentials.
We want to ensure that
when we authorize a client,
we are authorizing it based
upon a non-replayable attribute
of the client,
versus identifying
the client through
something like a token
that itself can be replayed.
Thus we want to prevent
impersonations by using
something like an IP address or
a credential that is based upon
a cryptographically signed
certificate, for example,
that cannot be replayed.
The next is we want to
ensure that in the case
there is a client that can
access PII on behalf of an end
user, it can only do so when it
is acting on behalf of that end
user, and not when
if it is compromised
that it can gain access
to PII without a valid end
user that actually has
authority on that data.
And lastly, we want to ensure
that all insider access are
logged down to authorized
clients that can implement
the right set of
checks and obfuscation,
et cetera, before
granting access to data
to a privileged insider.
Thus we will now
talk about how we
can implement these set of
control mechanisms with Anthos.
A key tool for implementing
these principles
that we just talked about
is Anthos Service Mesh.
We'll walk you through how
Anthos Service Mesh can
help you secure workload access,
followed by access to data,
and to mitigate privileged
insider risks as well.
So the first step is to ensure
that you can secure workload
access without taking a
dependency on the security
of the underlying network.
This does not mean that
you are not securing
the underlying network.
We still recommend that you
have the right kind of parameter
security, and have a
minimum set of segmentation
for [INAUDIBLE] out
access, ensuring
that your backends are not
exposed to the internet,
for example.
Having said that, once you
do that it, as we described
before, that is not sufficient
for modern production
environments.
So thus, we now will talk
about how you will actually
grant access within your
production network context.
So the first step is
to ensure that we only
grant access to
authorized network peers,
to authorized clients.
And we recommend
doing that using
a certificate-based identity.
The advantage of a
certificate-based identity is
that it is not replayable,
because the receiver
of a certificate cannot
replay it without also being
in possession of
the private keys.
Thus, it prevents
impersonation attacks.
And the use of mutual
TLS for authentication
also implies that
you get encryption
in transit, another key property
that we described earlier.
The value of Anthos Service
Mesh in this context
is to automatically manage
your certificates and keys
for tens of thousands of
workloads in your production.
The next step is to ensure
that you use an authorization
policy that can reason
about these identities,
and in addition
to that, can also
reason about
additional attributes,
like namespace, and IPs, as
needed in order to grant access
to a network peer.
Anthos Service Mesh
provide such a policy that
is integrated into the Mesh.
All of this implies that your
security can be policy-driven
and is not baked
into the code, thus
your application developers
can focus on business logic
rather than on security.
The next step, after
having secured workload
to workload access, is to
secure access to user data
by a workload.
So in addition to ensuring
that you have the right client,
in order to gain
access to user data,
we want to ensure that the
client is accessing on behalf
of the right end user.
And we can do this by ensuring
that the client presents
a valid end user
credential that has
the right kind of claims to
access the data on the backend.
Again, Anthos Service
Mesh provides you
with a policy engine
that can A, validate
that that is a valid
end user credential that
is being presented,
with the right signer,
and that actually, has
not expired, for example.
And it can also reason about the
claims in that JWT credential,
to ensure that the credential
has the right kind of claim
so that the data can be
accessed, based upon what
the end user has
access to, and not
on the privilege of the
credit card front end itself.
The last piece that Anthos
Service Mesh helps you secure
is insider access.
With respect to insider
access, Anthos Service Mesh
ensures that your insider
can only gain access
to the right frontend, because
Anthos Service Mesh will grant
access to data, let's say,
based upon a valid end user
credential, and your
credit card backend
will grant access
to data if it's
a valid privileged insider.
But at the Mesh layer, you can
ensure that this valid insider
is actually accessing the
data via the right frontend,
such as the case tool over
here, which could implement
obfuscation of PII as needed.
It will deny access of the
same privileged insider
where to deploy their
own personal script,
and then tried to gain
access to data without going
through the keys too.
A key principle
for granting access
to sensitive information on
infrastructure to an insider
is to ensure that we strongly
authenticate the insider.
And this is done in
Google Cloud Platform
through a product called
Identity-Aware Proxy.
Identity-Aware Proxy users
BeyondCorp principles to ensure
that the user identity
is authenticated based
on multiple factors, such
as the client device,
attributes, and IP address.
For example, you can ensure
that you only grant access
to sensitive data when the
insider accesses the case
tool from a well-managed
corporate device that
is secure.
This ensures that you're
only granting access
to the right person,
via the right frontend,
coming from the right
endpoint device, for example.
So to summarize, Anthos
provides features
for securing access
in productions based
upon zero trust principles.
The first being
Anthos Service Mesh,
which provides mutual TLS
for encryption in transit
and for a stronger
authentication
and authorization.
Anthos Service Mesh allows
you to secure access
across clusters and
across VPC networks.
It also allows you
to secure access
based upon end user context, and
not just on the peer context.
Identity-Aware Proxy
enables you to grant
access to your insiders based
upon strong authentication
of the end user
itself, and based
upon things like the device
context and IP address,
for example.
It's integrated with
Anthos Service Mesh,
and it can also support
third party identities,
so you can bring your
own identity provider
and use that with
Identity-Aware Proxy.
Lastly, one of the things that
we did not talk about before
is Kubernetes network policy.
It is still important in this
context of zero trust access
because it provides you with
the segmentation technology that
works within a single cluster.
So thus, you can use something
like Kubernetes network policy
to implement a policy
that says the frontend,
which is internet-facing, cannot
directly access the backend
by bypassing the middle tier.
Right, so this kind of a
[INAUDIBLE] segmentation
can be implemented with the
Kubernetes network policy,
and it adds defense
in depth on top
of what you have at the base
infrastructure security level,
and the security that you
implement using Anthos Service
Mesh.
So, to summarize zero
trust production security
can be achieved with
three principles, which
is only trusted code and
configuration can be deployed
to production,
trust is associated
with workload and user, and not
just with the network location,
and all access to sensitive
data and infrastructure
is granted to the
right network peers,
and under the
right user context.
Thank you.